[Music]
good evening two valley families are
grieving after two teenage girls were
killed while crossing a busy street last
night
thanks for joining us here at six
o'clock i'm denise valdez and i'm
kirsten joyce that crash happened just
east of the strip at maryland and katy
police say ebony whitaker was driving
drunk when she allegedly hit the teens
around dinner time
she is now facing a number of charges
including dui and reckless driving
joe moeller spoke to the family of one
of the victims he joins us live from
where the crash happened
joe kirsten this crash has really left
two families
devastated now here at this intersection
you can still see what is left over that
car came
down maryland parkway here south you can
see this tree is
now completely knocked over where this
car stopped and this
flowers and candles are here on this
tree and just a few minutes ago we saw a
family come and drop off some roses here
for these victims
now the coroner identified the two teens
as sitlali mora and
nellie amaya ramirez the coroner says
they're both 16 years old
now nelly does not live too far from
this area with her family
and her family says their lives are
forever changed
it is a tragedy that no family wants to
go through
we're in shock we have to see how we can
come forward due to the accident
nelson reyes says his step-daughter
nellie amaya was killed when crossing a
street
with her friend at maryland parkway and
katie avenue
this is the gofundme posted online he
says she was with her best friend sitla
lee more at the time
he says nelly will be missed
very nice baby girl she was great we're
feeling a lot because it happened from
night today
police say the driver ebony whitaker
failed to maintain control of the
mercedes she was in
they say she went up a curb onto the
sidewalk eventually hitting the teens
this is a photo posted to metro's
twitter they say this was preventable
reyes and other family tell us nelly was
an only child
my wife is devastated in the room she
can't even stand up
because she's in shock she's bad we
spoke to nellie's aunt vicki ramirez who
says the suspect's choices are taking a
toll on
two families if they are going to drink
if they are going to go out to enjoy do
it
moderately because they destroy the
family with their loss
now back out here live you're taking a
live look at this memorial where this
happened this is growing this happened
24 hours ago like we just mentioned the
family just dropped off
about a dozen roses right here at this
location now the father did say they are
going to have a tough time with funeral
expenses there is that gofundme that was
set up if you would like to help
we do have a link to that up on our
website that is 8newsnow.com
reporting live i'm joe moore i'll send
it back to you